[Music]
what
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
question and answer program I'd like to
know my name is Steven bore I'm the
president of Secrets
unsealed um we Delight in receiving your
questions we do the research we do
everything possible to find the answer
if there is an answer in the Bible uh if
you want to send us your questions you
can do so electronically at the
following email address
TVM tv.org once again tvsm tv.org I have
with me here Daniel Miranda good friend
uh he is the associate speaker here at
Secrets un seal one of the associate
speakers uh he also is in charge of the
Spanish work here at our ministry and uh
I greatly respect his knowledge uh he's
a lot younger than I am uh so by the
time he becomes my age if the Lord
terries uh he's going to be a super PhD
in Bible knowledge it's always good to
have you with us Daniel thank you Pastor
bour it is a privilege to contribute to
this beautiful Ministry and a privilege
to learn from you as well praise the
Lord and learn from you also uh we don't
want to begin without having a word of
prayer so I'd like to ask Pastor mid
that to have a word of prayer for us
okay let's bow ahead for prayer Heavenly
Father once again we come before your
awesome presence we thank you for this
program thank you for those who are
watching for those who have sent out
their questions we pray Lord that the
Holy Spirit may lead us and guide us
into the study that we are going to have
today we don't want to say more than
what it is written so we pray Lord that
the answers that that we give may be in
light of your word and may also help
those who are watching to find clearer
answers to Bible questions in the name
of Jesus amen
amen well in our last program we ran out
of time in dealing with a particular
question about whether
the Satan's attempt to counterfeit the
second coming of Christ will take place
before or after the close of probation
uh the person who wrote the question uh
suggests that uh as well as others that
the Satan's attempt to counterfeit the
second coming will take place before the
close of Probation and it's going to
bring the whole world together in
keeping Sunday as a day of rest because
when Satan counterfeits the coming
second coming of Christ and he appears
as a dazzling being
uh people are going to say well you know
uh he says we're supposed to keep Sunday
Christ is the individual and so now
everybody needs to keep Sunday and you
know that's basically the the key point
in understanding this because let me
confess something I used to believe that
before and uh the reason I used to
believe it I had not listened it from
anyone but I was studying and when Ellen
y says that when Satan tries to
counterfeit Jesus's Second Coming that
he will tell them that Sunday is the day
of worship so in my mind I was like if
Sunday is the day of worship and Satan
is urging them to keep Sunday what what
what sense does it make to do that
during the time of trouble when the
saints are sealed if he will not be able
to deceive them so that was the
reasoning but then starting in light of
Matthew 24 again and the chronological
and sequential order of Matthew 24 then
it makes perfect sense to me that it
happens is before and I believe you're
going to explain why he will try to do
it or he will try to deceive God's
people in the time of trouble even
though they are sealed it's his last
resort exactly he knows that God has
said that he's not going to be able to
deceive the elect he knows that uh but
the devil is the devil he doesn't give
up you know I like to use this
illustration uh does Satan know that
after the Millennium he is not going to
be able to conquer the city yeah he does
if he doesn't he's not very smart
because he can read it in Revelation 20
that's right that all of the wicked led
by Satan are going to surround the city
and fire is going to come down from
heaven and consume them they're never
going to attack the city so here's my
question why when the wicked resurrect
Satan is going to Rally them to attack
the city if he already knows Revelation
20 says he's not going to be able to he
still Harbor a hope that he will be able
to overcome he cherishes a hope the hope
that he can counteract the word of God
yes that's what he's that all throughout
history he doesn't just lay down and say
oh what's the use no the devil is the
devil and even though he knows that God
says that he's going to be destroyed
he's not going to be able to conquer the
city he's still going to do it yeah
because because he's evil he's the
personification of evil so does he know
that during the tribulation the Great
Tribulation he's not going to be able to
deceive the elect of course he knows
that and you know some people say oh but
it says in Matthew 24 he will deceive if
possible the very elect so I guess it is
possible then so it must be during
probationary time the problem with that
is that verse 31 of Matthew 24 says that
when Jesus comes he comes to gather his
elect which means that if he comes
together his elect his elect will not
dece exactly see you have to read the
entire chapter in detail uh to not reach
wrong conclusions um so last time we
were dealing uh pastor with the fact
that Matthew 24 is in chronological
order and we notice the word then and
other temporal expressions in the
chapter that indicate that one event
takes place after the other correct uh
the abomination of desolation Ellen
White identifies as the national Sunday
law in the United States of America
that's verse 15 and then the very next
verse verse 16 speaks about the flight
of God's people and then verse 21 speaks
about uh the Great tribul
there's a little tribulation in verse 9
it says then you will have tribulation
and they will arise and want to kill you
but the word is qualified in verse 21
It's the Great Tribulation the megali
tribulation and then in that context you
have then you you know false Christ
were're going to appear and then they're
going to say if he's in the desert Jesus
says don't go out you know if he's in in
the inner rooms don't go there uh so
this is taking place during the Great
Tri
right after the close of probation
according to the chronological sequence
of Matthew 24 now something that we
didn't do last time was to prove that
the word to the word then uh which
refers to an event that occurs after
another event this then this and then
this I want us to notice in Matthew 25
and we're going to have to read several
verses Matthew chapter 25 where the word
tote is used to refer to sequential
event
time and again Matthew 25 and I'll give
you the numbers of the verses and you
can read them um Matthew
25:1 Matthew
25:1 then the Kingdom of Heaven shall be
likened to 10 virgins who took their
lambs and went out to meet their
bridegroom okay verse seven verse seven
then all those virgins arose and trimmed
their
lambs okay verse 16 verse 16 then
he who had received the five talents
went and traded with them and made
another five talents verse 24 verse 24
it says then he who had received the one
Talent came and said Lord I knew you to
be a hard man reaping where you have not
sown and Gathering where you have not
scattered seed verse 27 verse 27 so you
ought to have deposited my money with
the bankers and at of my coming I would
have received back my own with in
interest verse
31 when the son of man comes in his
glory and all the Holy Angels with him
then he will sit on the throne of his
glory are we dealing with all sequential
events here one right after the other
verse 34 Verse 34 then the king will say
to those on his right hand come you
blessed of my father inherit the Kingdom
prepared for you from the foundation of
the world verse 37 verse 37 then the
right will answer him saying Lord when
did we see you hungry and feed you or
thirsty and give you drink verse 41 then
he will also say to those on the left
hand depart from me you cursed into the
Everlasting fire prepare for the devil
and his angels verse 44 verse
44 then they also will answer him saying
Lord when did we see you hungry or or
thirsty or a stranger or naked or sick
or in prison and did not minister to you
verse 45 then he will answer them saying
assuredly as I say to you in as much as
you did not do it to one of the least of
these you did not do it to me so how do
we understand the word then in all these
verses sequential order in sequential
order yeah uh let's notice one more
example and there's multiple ones uh
chapter 26 chapter 26 let's read several
from chapter 26 verse three verse three
it says then the chief priest the
scribes and the Elders of the people
assembled at the palace of the high
priest who was called cayapas verse uh
14 verse 14 then one of the 12 called
Judas is kiot went to the chief priests
verse 25 verse 25 then Judas who was
betraying him answered and said Rabbi is
it I he said to him you have said it
verse 30 31 verse 31 then Jesus said to
them all of you will be made me will be
made will be made will be made to
stumble because of me this night for it
is written I will strike the shepherd
and the sheep of the flock will be
scattered verse 36 verse 36 then Jesus
came with them to the place called
Gethsemane and said to the disciples sit
here while I go and pray over there
verse 38 then he said to them my soul is
exceedingly sorrowful even to death stay
here and watch with me verse
45 and verse 45 then he came to his
disciples and said to them are you still
sleeping and resting behold the hour is
at hand and the son of man is being
betrayed into the hands of Sinners verse
50 verse 50 but Jesus said to him friend
why have you come then they came and
laid hands on Jesus and took him verse
15 2 verse 52 but Jesus said to him put
your sword in its place for all who take
the sword will perish By The Sword verse
54 verse 54 how then could the
scriptures be fulfilled that it must
happen
thus verse 56 verse 56 but all this was
done that the scriptures of the prophets
might be fulfilled then all the
disciples forsook him and fled verse 65
verse 65
then the high priest tore his clothes
saying he has spoken blasphemy what
further need do we have of Witnesses
look now you have heard his blasphemy
verse 67 then they spattered in his face
and bit him and others struck him with
the palms of their hands verse
74 then he began to curse and swear
saying I do not know the man immediately
a rooster crowd
so let me ask you then all of the VIN
that are used in these verses are they
sequential yep they are this then this
then this then this and then this the
word that is used is not Kai Kai is is
translated usually and and exactly you
know this and this and this not
necessarily always in chronological
order but in all of these examples and
this is right after Matthew chapter 24
we're did 25 and 26 everything
that that you have is in chronological
order when the you word then is used so
in Matthew 24 nine times the word then
is used it must refer to a series of
chronological events correct and the
attempted counterfeit Second Coming is
during the Great Tribulation clearly and
um you know you can look up the word to
uh in a concordance and uh and check me
out it refers to one event that lead
leads after another event now last time
when we ended uh I was reading from
great controversy Pages 624 and 625 and
let me just summarize uh the counterfeit
Second Coming is Satan's crowning act
which means that it's the last
one uh he's going to attempt to
personate Christ he will make it appear
like Christ has come he will appear like
a majestic being in dazzling brightness
much like the description of Christ in
Revelation chapter 1
uh he his glory is unsurpassed by
anything that mortal eyes have seen and
then the multitudes are going to shout
out in Triumph that Christ has come and
Jesus is going to lift his hands and
he's going to bless them uh Satan is
going to bless them like Jesus blessed
the disciples when he was on Earth uh
his voice is going to be soft and
subdued uh Yet full of Melody and Ellen
White refers to this as the strong all
almost overmastering delusion
and then uh here's the key that this is
dealing with the same event of Matthew
24: 23 and 24 um she says but the people
of God will not be misled the teachings
of this false Christ are not in
accordance with the scriptures his
blessing blessing is pronounced upon the
worshippers of the Beast and His Image
the very class upon whom the Bible
declares that God's un unmingled wrath
shall be poured out and now no notice
and furthermore Satan is not permitted
to counterfeit the manner of Christ's
Advent the Savior has warned his people
against deception upon this point and is
clearly foretold the manner of his
second coming and now she's going to
quote Matthew 24 there shall be arise
false Christ and false prophets and
shall show great signs and wonders in so
much that if it were possible they shall
deceive the very elect wherefore if they
shall say unto you behold he is in the
desert go not forth behold he is in the
secret Chambers believe it not for the
lightning cometh out of the East and
shineth even unto the West so shall also
the coming of the son of man be this
coming there's no possibility of
counterfeiting it will be universally
known witnessed by the whole world so
she's quoting several verses from
Matthew 24 in this context of the Great
Tribulation so I mean it's so absolutely
clear that the counterfeit Second Coming
is taking place uh after the close of
probation during the Great Tribulation
now o want to read uh in you know a
program like this it's not fun reading a
lot uh but uh I do have to read these
things because they help us explain the
answer to the question that was made um
the earlier uh passage in volume four of
spirit of Prophecy page 441 and four 442
uh is similar but not identical uh Ellen
White wrote The Wrath of Satan increases
as time grows short and his work of
deceit and destruction reaches its
culmination in the time of trouble okay
now here's the context uh so the Wrath
is going to increase as time grows short
his work of Deceit and destruction
reaches its culmination in the time of
trouble and and that's Sky because he it
says that the work of Deceit and
destruction reaches its culmination that
means that he's going to also try to
deceive during the time of trouble yes
and then and it says God's long
suffering has ended so the time of
trouble is after the close of probation
clearly the world has rejected his Mercy
despised his love and trampled upon his
law the wicked have passed the boundary
of their probation and the Lord
withdraws his protection and leaves them
to the mercy of the leader they have
chosen and then notice the next
paragraph As the crowning act when is
the crowning act the Final Act the time
of trouble time of trouble mhm after God
has withdrawn his Mercy clearly as the
crowning act in the great drama
deception Satan himself will attempt to
personate Christ the church has long
professed to look to the savior's Advent
as the consummation of her hopes Now The
Great Deceiver will make it appear that
Christ has come in different parts of
the earth Satan will manifest himself
among men as a majestic being of
dazzling brightness this is almost
identical to the passage that I read
from great controversy the glory that
surrounds him is unsurpassed by anything
that mortal eyes have yet beheld the
shot of Triumph rings out upon the air
Christ has come Christ has come the
people prostrate themselves in adoration
before him while he lifts up his hands
and pronounces a blessing upon them as
Christ blessed his disciples when he was
personally upon the Earth his voice is
soft and subdued Yet full of melodyy
Melody in gentle compassionate tones he
presents some of the same gracious
Heavenly truths which the Savior savior
uttered he heals the diseases of the
people and then in his assumed character
of Christ he claims to have changed the
Sabbath to Sunday and commands all to
hallow the day which he has blessed he
de that those who persist in keeping
holy the seventh day are blaspheming his
name by refusing to listen to his angels
sent to them with light and Truth this
is the strong almost overmastering
delusion so let me ask you when is the
when is the strong over almost
overmastering delusion when does that
take place well during the time of
trouble clearly after the close of
probation very clearly the first
paragraph says
uh the Lord withdraws his protection and
leaves them to the mercy of the leader
they have chosen and then I want to read
also from Last Day Events 164 and 165
because this give us gives us the
moment in which Satan is going to
counterfeit the second coming attempt to
counterfeit the second coming of Christ
Last Day Events 164 165 Satan sees that
he is about to lose his case he cannot
sweep in the whole
world uh has he swept in the whole world
at this point except the remnant yes he
it says he cannot sweep in the whole
world he's already deceive the whole
world except for the elect notice what
it continues saying he makes one last
desperate effort this is the last effort
to overcome the faithful by deception so
who is his Target to deceive the world
no no his Target is to deceive whom the
elect the elect so it says he does this
um he makes one last effort to overcome
the faithful by deception he does this
impersonating Christ is that the same
thing that's in great controversy yes he
clothes himself with the garments of
royalty which have accurately been
described in the vision of John he has
power to do this he will appear to his
deluded followers the Christian world
who deceive received not the love of the
truth but had pleasure and
unrighteousness as Christ coming the
second time he proclaims himself Christ
he is belied to be Christ a beautiful
Majestic being clothed with majesty and
with soft voice and pleasant words with
Glory unpassed by anything their mortal
eyes have yet beheld then in his
deceived deluded followers set up a
shout of Victory Christ has come the
second time Christ has come he has
lifted up his hands just as he did when
he was upon the Earth and blessed us the
Saints look on with amazement will they
also be deceived will until they worship
Satan who is the target of Satan at this
point is it to unite the whole world no
all the wicked no his Target is the
elect because they are the only ones in
the world that have not bent the knee at
this point the whole world has already
bent the knee the Saints look on with
amazement they will also be will they
also be deceived will they worship Satan
angels of God are about them a clear
firm musical voices heard look up
there's one object before the praying
ones see this it's the elect
a Target the final and eternal salvation
of their souls this object was before
them constantly that Immortal Life was
promised to those who endure un the end
oh how Earnest and fervent have been
their desires the Judgment in eternity
were in view their eyes by faith were
fixed in the Blazing Throne before which
the white robed ones were to stand this
restrained them from Indulgence of sin
and now comes the key portion of this
statement and Last Day Events 164 and
165 one effort
more it's going to be the last
effort and then Satan's last device is
employed he hears the unceasing cry for
Christ to come for Christ to what
deliver them to deliver
them the last strategy is to personate
Christ and make them think their prayers
are answered so what are God's people
doing at this point they're crying out
day and night for God to what to deliver
them deliver them from whom from the
enemies persecuting them because the
death decree is given because they are
the lone
resistors and and so the purpose of the
counterfeit second coming by Satan is
not to deceive the whole
world they're already deceived the
purpose is to deceive the
elect whom he know knows he can't
deceive but he's going to do it anyway
because he always Harbors the hope that
he can counterfeit that he can overcome
uh or contradict the world of God uh so
notice the Expressions one effort more
last device last strategy and the
unceasing cry for Christ to come and to
deliver them and and then Satan comes he
counterfeits the second coming which
he's not really able to do and he says
you've been crying out to be delivered I
am Christ I have come to deliver you
that's why it's the almost overmastering
delusion and how important it is that we
might be grounded in the scriptures
because it's going to be something as it
says dazzling and Majestic yeah you know
as I was reading as as we were going
over this quote I was thinking how much
preparation we still need for that time
yeah to have that complete trust in
Jesus and and have that close
relationship with him that we may
identify the voice of a stranger from
the voice of Jesus Christ that even if
Satan comes with the Majestic figure of
Jesus Christ and even if he looks just
like Christ as it is described in
Revelation chapter 1 still we will know
that that's not Christ because we will
have a close relationship with Jesus and
we will be able to identify who the
right and true Jesus is yeah and in fact
it'll be through the scriptures EXA
because because the Saints are going to
detect immediately Satan's reason for
trying to counterfeit the second coming
of Christ uh it's because first of all
the Bible tells us that uh Jesus is not
going to touch the Earth MH and
secondly uh Satan is going to be saying
that Sunday is the day of
rest and we will know the Bible says
it's the Sabbath exactly so because they
know from the scriptures how Jesus Will
Come
and they know from the scriptures that
the Sabbath is the day of rest they will
not be deceived uh let me just read here
a statement from Christian experience
and teaching page 100 remember crying
out to be delivered when does that take
place well here it's explained I saw
that the Four Angels would hold the Four
Winds until Jesus work was done in the
sanctuary and then will come the seven
last plagues these plagues enraged the
wicked against the righteous they
thought that we had brought the
judgments of God upon them them and that
if they could rid the Earth of us the
plagues would then be stayed is this
happening after the close of probation
yeah of course it is a decree went forth
to slay the Saints so when is the death
decree against God's Saints it's after
the close of probation the plagues are
falling that's right so it says a decree
went forth to slay the Saints which
caused them to do what cry to cry day
and night day and night for what
Deliverance is that what we found in the
previous statements for deliverance this
was the time of Jacob's
trouble then all the saints here it is
again cried out with angues of spirit
and were delivered by the voice of God
so in uh in the light of the previous
statement the previous statement says
that God's people are praying you know
praying crying out to Lord Deliver us
and then Satan attempts to counterfeit
the second com says I've come to answer
your prayers where this amplifies when
they're going to be crying out and when
they're going to be delivered it's
during the time of trouble after the
close of probation um and you know I
could read another statement early
writings page 34 where once again you
find God's people crying out day and
night for deliverance their cry comes up
before God and God delivers them by his
voice at the close of the time of
trouble so uh so going back to the
question we took two programs to answer
this one question and the reason why I
decided to dedicate so much time to this
is because this is going around like
grassfire like a California grassfire
it's going all over the place and I had
one individual call me and says Pastor
I've heard something so exciting and it
is that Satan is going to counterfeit
the second coming of Christ with a
purpose of bringing the entire world
together against God's people well the
quotations say that it's not to bring
the whole world together because the
whole world is together already exactly
it's to deceive if possible the very
elect mhm and uh and so I hope that this
explanation is useful uh for uh the
person who asked the question and for
all of those who uh are listening to
these points of view and may may we not
trust in the testimony of our senses
that's right may we only trust in the
testimony of the word of God can't trust
your eyes your ears your feelings your
emotions your impressions your
intuitions you must live by every word
that proceeds out of the mouth of God
Amen well folks thank you so much for
joining us uh I trust that our study
together has been useful to you thank
you for sending us your questions and
we'll see you next time God bless
[Music]